now that leads to one more topic that i
want to get to i was on wqam in miami
this morning with zach krantz joe rose
who's been hosting that show for years
and i've been on that show every friday
morning for years uh joe was off zach
and i were talking about
the rogers situation and he raised the
question of
how many teams would rogers make
into
super bowl contenders immediately if the
trade happened right now regardless of
who they currently have and obviously
there are a lot of teams that already
are super bowl contenders
without aaron rodgers or yes they're
they're already like the bills yeah the
bills are a super bowl contender with
josh allen if for some reason the bills
would decide to trade for aaron rodgers
which they would never do because they
have josh allen they're still a super
bowl contender so what i've done is i've
gone through team by team
and
i'm curious about the teams that
currently aren't in my mind based upon
their their present quarterback
situation true super bowl contenders
does rogers make them into contenders
yes or no
now
before i get to that here are the teams
that i think are contenders
with or without
aaron rodgers super bowl contenders with
or without rogers on the team
the bills the patriots and yes i believe
the patriots are super bowl contenders
given
the upgrades they've made this off
season and the presence
of bill belichick as the head coach
the steelers
the browns the ravens the titans the
colts
the
chiefs and the chargers in the afc those
are the teams that i think are super
bowl contenders with or without aaron
rodgers in the nfc
the cowboys
and even though i think washington's
going to win the division i think if it
works for the cowboys they're more
likely to be a super bowl contender if
that makes any sense so i'm going to say
the cowboys the only super bowl
contender out of the nfc east for now
even though i think washington wins the
division
the buccaneers the saints
the rams
the seahawks and the 49ers those are all
the teams that are super bowl contenders
if for some reason they would decide hey
let's go ahead and get aaron rodgers and
the packers will trade him now here are
the teams that become contenders
for the super bowl
who i currently think aren't
you put in aaron rodgers and they're
contenders
the dolphins become super bowl
contenders they currently aren't
the raiders become super bowl contenders
in my mind they currently aren't the
broncos become super bowl contenders in
my mind they currently aren't washington
becomes a super bowl contender in my
mind even though i think they're going
to win the division i don't think
they're going to have enough to punch
through to the super bowl
the vikings become super bowl contenders
in my mind they currently aren't the
bears
they're not going to do it but they
would become super bowl contenders in my
mind they currently aren't
and then the others i've added
the panthers
and the cardinals i don't think either
team is a super bowl contender right now
i think they would be with aaron rodgers
the teams i struggled with
were the falcons
and
the giants i put them on the nose side
and these are the teams that i think
aaron rodgers wouldn't make them into
super bowl contenders jets bengals
texans jaguars
giants eagles lions falcons
but the two on which i was the closest
are the giants and the falcons and it's
no coincidence that they're nfc teams
because the afc is so damn top heavy
i don't care who the quarterback is of
the jets this year they're not a super
bowl contender they're not ready yet
from a personnel standpoint the bengals
have a long way to go to be super bowl
contenders the texans have the worst
roster in the nfl right now and the
jaguars have a long way to go as well
not that the jaguars would want aaron
rodgers if the opportunity arose or the
bengals for that matter or the jets for
that matter again there aren't many
teams that would want him right now i
think the broncos are the clear leader
right now
the raiders as i said could get into it
and the other side of it too and i'm
glad i thought of this
rogers has to want to go
to the team that would trade for him
and some of you will say in response to
that but he doesn't have a no trade
clause well
for a starting quarterback
a no trade clause is meaningless
because
think about this if you're the general
manager of a team
and you are trading for a quarterback a
guy that you want to come in and set the
tone for the organization show up stay
late hold teammates accountable check
every box and then some be the face of
the team at least from the locker room
standpoint
if he doesn't want to be there
do you really want him
i think a key ingredient
to making it work especially at this
stage of the year is to have full buy-in
from the quarterback so hey the dolphins
become super bowl contenders with aaron
rodgers but if aaron rodgers doesn't
want to live and play in miami this year
if he doesn't want to be on the dolphins
this year you're not going to make that
trade
because he don't want to be there he may
not show up remember when richard
seymour was traded from the patriots to
the raiders and it took a few days for
him to recognize oh god i've been traded
from one of the best teams in the nfl
one of the worst at the time the raiders
were one of the worst
it took him a while to realize i just
better go now it's easier to do that
with a non-quarterback
a quarterback can say fine i'll show up
but don't expect me to do all the stuff
that a quarterback
who's all in would do and i think it's
one of the reasons why the bears didn't
go after carson wentz remember they were
linked to carson wentz wentz didn't want
to go there wence doesn't have no trade
clause it doesn't matter if wence
doesn't want to be in chicago the bears
aren't going to waste their time trading
for him so that's the other thing to
keep in mind if he gets traded this year
i think it's the broncos maybe the
raiders
after this year there will be more teams
at the table the question is which teams
would aaron rodgers be willing to play
for the problem is i mean think about it
the west coast teams that's where he
wants to go well the ramps have matthew
stafford and they gave up a lot to get
him
they're not going to give up on him
after one year the 49ers who the hell
knows what they're going to do because
they wanted aaron rodgers and they're so
desperate to atone for their failure to
draft patrick mahomes and their failure
to take tom brady up on his interest in
the team that maybe they would do
something crazy like throw everyone
overboard and go get aaron rodgers trey
lance for aaron rodgers straight up
maybe that would happen who knows
the raiders and the broncos i think
would still be the two teams to watch
next year but maybe the possibility of
having more teams at the table could
leverage one of those teams to give up
more and of course from roger's
perspective he doesn't want the team
he's going to to give up too much
because he's got to go play for that
team you don't want the team to be
gutted you don't want the team's draft
picks for the next several years to all
be gone
as part of the transaction that brought
you there
so
up
interesting dynamics to say the least
and we'll find out in a couple of weeks
whether he shows up but the bottom line
is i think if he shows up that gives him
a better chance to get out this year
instead of next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports